I'm going to show you two of my all-time
favorite diagrams it's a way of linking
numbers as they go from one to the next
and you a lot of people will have heard
of or I'm sure you'll have a video on
this somewhere about happy numbers
equals one this makes one under seven
and I'm not going to do happy numbers
I'm going to do a thing on the number
145 if that's okay and I'll get to that
in my second diagram
my first diagram is that you have happy
numbers so for example let's do the
happy number let's do 13 right you can
square both those digits and add them
together so if you square 1 you get 1 if
you square 3 you get 9 and so that will
give you 10 ok and if you repeat the
process you then square 1 you get 1 is
goes or you get 0 that will give you 1
right and so 13 through a chain ends up
at 1 and there are other numbers higher
up so let's say you had 23 and you are
squared 2 you get 4 we square 3 you get
9 you get 13 23 will lead into 13 as
will 32 doesn't matter what order
they're in in fact over here we could
have gone in that way by 31 and what I'm
going to do now is very quickly draw for
you all the two-digit numbers because
there are some three-digit numbers we
could have come into 10 130 would work
just as well and that will have come in
from 97 because if you square 9 and
square 7 add them together you go 230
which of course means at 79 we'll do the
same thing and we could have got there
from 94 or we could have come in from 49
and if we come in from 49 we could have
got there from 70 or from 7 would give
us 49 because it's just the 7 and on the
other side over here we could have got
to 32 via 44 and we actually could have
got to 1 from 100 we could have got into
a hundred from 86 would have got us to
100 as would have 68 the great thing
about 68 is different to 86 is you can
get there from 28 or you can come in
from 82 and you can get into 82 from
either 19 or 91 and those are all the
two-digit numbers that end up in this
happy tree and I call that process of
squaring both the digits or all the
digits and then adding them happen so
you could call this the half of a
keishon tree and these are all the
extreme points so actually that there is
the top of that branch that's the top of
that branch that's the top of that
branch and the rest of them feed down
and obviously a lot of the forks you
just get the redundant vestigial I guess
number which leads in at the same
because it doesn't matter on the order
of the digits okay classification
catification tree there you are now the
diagram I really want to show you the
reason I'm talking about 145 is not the
half of a Cashion tree do this with 83
that's probably a good start 83 is not a
happy number the reason 83 is not happy
none but we'll put it over here is that
if you keep happy for heating 8 bear
with me
83 you do not end up at 1 but we're off
where else can you end up right what
happened great in square 3 and you add
them together you end up with 73 which
as you will have realized by now could
also happen if you started at 38 so I
put that in for completeness sake 73 if
you now are square 7 and square 3 that
will give you 58 if you square v square
8 that will give you 89 if you square 8
square 9 you'll get the 145 that I was
mentioning before if you Square 1 4 and
5 and out all those together you get 42
a rather popular number if you square
those you'll get 220 if you go from 20
you'll get 2 for 4 go straight to 16 16
will give you thirty seven and then 37
will give you 58 and at this point we're
back in the loop so now two things
happen when you start with the two-digit
number and start squaring and adding the
digits you either end up down here at
one so you can consider this like a
treat so I call this the half of a case
on tree and it all grows out of one or
you end up in this in this coil right
and all the other numbers feed into this
coil so I call these are the happy
numbers and I call these the Mellen coil
Mellen coiling numbers that'll work
so you've got the happy numbers and the
melancholic numbers and because I and a
thorough fastidious kind of guy I'm
going to fill in very quickly if you
don't mind bearing with me for a second
Brady I'm going to fill in all the other
melon coiling numbers 37 has quite a
tree that comes off it you can get 237
from either 106 which that is a 6 which
feeds in from 95 and
59 or alternatively you can also get
there via 61 which is kind of cool
61 are you can get to there from 65
which gives us 74 and 47 which comes off
75 and 57 where as 61 also gives us 56
which leads up to 45 million air 63
that's 36 and down here we end up with 6
and 60 and there's another end this is
the map which consists of two parts of
how all the 2 digit numbers link
together this is a structure for all
two-digit numbers when you have a fork 8
them so where you square all the digits
and add them together and you'll notice
it requires a few three-digit numbers to
form the structure so there's a
three-digit number there's the 1 4 5
which the video is all about and there's
a few other ones is 1 1 3 hiding down
here where else is one sneaky and
there's 1 3 0 snakes and over there and
they're vital for the structure or other
3 digit or higher numbers filter into
this diagram this is the complete
structure for all the two-digit numbers
everything let's draw the 3 digit one as
well ok I'll get some know so you can if
you have it it doesn't add any further
detail to this and what I love is all
numbers of any size will filter down
into one of two situations and either
filter down to one or they were filtered
down into the melon coil and this is it
and of course from here you can go
absolutely wild and I'm going to refrain
from this level of wildness but you
could look at what happens when you are
cube or your digits right so if you cube
all your digits you get more scenarios
you get some numbers that go in there
different sizes and types of coils there
are different ways to end up at one
there are because you always get one
because things like a pausing will drop
you there there are points which there's
no points here is either one or it's the
spiral you get points in 3 because as
again I'm sure there are other videos
about narcissistic numbers is
it's in love with itself when you hit
our let's take 371 then our 1 cubed plus
3 cubed plus 7 cubed gives you 371 and
so you end up stuck and all things feed
into that point so and you can do it for
powers of four or five or there's an
infinite number of options there's a
type of infinite number of options there
and you can do it in different bases
mathematicians get a bit emotional when
we become base ten centric and there's
no reason why you can't generalize this
to other bases but anyway if you limit
yourself just to squaring in base ten
these are the two diagrams you get and
so I got bored and I made a quick
spreadsheet and I went through and I
classified all of this and drew the
diagram myself so this this was this was
me again bored in the pub with some
mates and we went through and classified
all the numbers they are
I
didn't come a crike this myself other
people very well could have done this
they don't want to claim ownership the
some what a pathetic name of melon
coiling numbers I did come up with but
again asking them described as not happy
numbers or unhappy numbers so then again
why they call happy numbers in the first
place it was a ridiculous name so this
particular interpretation of the a happy
numbers is of my invention and as always
I gave it a suitably pathetic name